[Musique]
il est depuis un an celui vers qui tous
les regards se tournent
l'homme au coeur de la faire le
personnage clé à l'origine de tous les
rebondissements c'est johnattan d'aval
qui le 28 octobre 2010 est à la
mi-journée signalé aux gendarmes la
disparition de son épouse alexia la
jeune femme ne serait pas revenue de son
footing matinal
on imagine toutes les hypothèses on est
dans le flou on sait pas si quelqu'un un
indice a vu quelqu'un quelque chose s'il
vous plaît faites nous en part sans part
à la gendarmerie mais pendant deux jours
plusieurs centaines de bénévoles prêtent
main forte aux gendarmes pour retrouver
l'employé de banque de 29 ans des chiens
un hélicoptère des plongeurs sont
mobilisés
le lundi 30 octobre le corps
partiellement brûlée d'alexia d'avaler
retrouvé dans un bois des moulins à
l'écart du parcours théorique de la
jeune femme sur les bords de saône
l'autopsié indiquent que l'asphyxient
est à l'origine de la mort quelques
jours plus tard to grey se mobilise pour
rendre hommage à la victime
devant plusieurs milliers de personnes
la famille avance unis johnattan
d'avaler isabelle fouillot prennent la
parole pour saluer la mémoire d'alexion
alexiens et ménagers et courir passion
qui nous réunissait temps dans l'effort
que dans les bonnes issement de notre
couple est la première supportrice
ou alors ces jeunes continuer à courir
nager en fumée c'est ce que ma fille
mauvaise car jusqu'ici pour tous
gray a été le funeste théâtre de
l'assassinât d'une joggeuse des courses
sont d'ailleurs organisées dans toute la
france comme ici à marseille à la
mémoire d'alexia sensiblement le même
âge
on est actif et en chausse ses baskets
pour aller courir quand on peut
donc on
s'identifier à alexia et c'est pour ça
que ça nous a touchés particulièrement à
gré les obsèques d'alexia d'aval attire
à nouveau des milliers d'anonymes autour
des proches et de la famille
les jours passent et toujours aucune
interpellation
l'enquète semble piétiner troublant les
habitants du secteur
et un peu de peur forcément mais c'est
tout après il ya des malades partout
faut pas être humain pour faire une
chose pareille
c'est terrible parce que nous pouvons
imaginer que il y à un individu
malfaisants qui habitent dans les
périmètres de 10 kg mais finalement
c'est après trois mois d'enquêté fin
janvier que tout s'accélère
johnatan d'aval est interpellé son
domicile perquisitionné en garde à vue à
besançon l'informaticien de 34 ans avoue
avoir étranglé son épouse
ses avocats plaident l'accident il avait
une relation de couple avec de très
fortes tensions qu alex y avait une
personnalité écrasante qui se sentait
complètement écrasée rabaissé et qu'à un
moment il y a eu des mots de trop nous
défendrons un jeune garçon qui dans une
crise de couple a effectivement de façon
accidentelle occasionné la mort de son
épouse mise en examen pour meurtre sur
conjoint johnattan d'aval a craqué en
toute fin de garde à vue sous la
pression d'éléments probants l'un de ses
voisins a entendu son véhicule
professionnel sortir de son domicile la
nuit précédant la disparition d'alexia
ce que confirme le gps sur le lieu de la
découverte du corps de la victime sont
identifiées des traces de pneus
correspondante à la même voiture et des
fragments de draps appartenant au couple
autant de preuves déterminantes pour les
enquêteurs ça s'est terminé
effectivement part par des aveux voilà
c'est mieux
c'est mieux pour nous même si ce n était
pas indispensable
incarcéré à dijon johnattan d'aval
encourt la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
celui qu une première expertise
psychiatrique décrit comme pervers et
manipulateur revient sur ses aveux fin
juin il nie désormais être l'auteur du
meurtre
accu son beau frère grégory gay et
invoque un pacte secret scellé par la
famille pour dissimuler les faits
c'est le dégoût le fluo disait ça donne
envie de vomir
ça donne le rôle coeur mais c'est ça
pour les parents la soeur et le beau
frère d'alexis à laval cette nouvelle
version de joe natale la troisième en
moins d'un an n'est qu'un mensonge de
plus il y a une certitude c'est que
madame dhalla été franchement massacré
est morte dans des conditions
extrêmement violente extrêmement
violente et c'est par accident ça va de
soi donc à partir de là il faut décrire
quelque chose qui colle un an après sa
mort
nul ne sait véritablement ce que furent
les dernières heures d'alexia d'aval
veuf éploré marie assassin ou victime
d'un complot familial pour les
enquêteurs johnattan d'aval reste en
tout cas jusqu'à présent le seul
meurtrier présumé d'alexia
[Musique]